بدات بطبيعه الحال النتائج بشكل رسمي يمكن
بكل اريحيها الحديث عنها نذهب الى الخريطه
التفاعليه ونتابع بعد فرز اثنين واربعين
فاصله 78% من الاصوات حتى الان بعد فرز
نقترب من الخمسين بالمئه من فرز الاصوات
والصوره كما نشاهد ليست كما هي الصوره في
المره الماضيه اسطنبول انقره الان مع
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان والذي
لاحظناه في اللحظات الاولى ان نسبه
المشاركه قلت انقره واسطنبول كانت في
الجوله الماضيه 90 بالمئه الان الاشارات
الاوليه 86% تقريبا بينهما النتائج حتى
الان قريبه في الشكل من حيث المناطق
الشرقيه ثابته طون جلي نتحدث عن مناطق
ديار بكر الاكراد نتحدث عن كل هذه المناطق
بما فيها
بما فيها اردهان بما فيها قارس التي هي
ليست بالضروره
مكون كردي فيها كبير لكن حزب الشعب
الجمهوري فيها قوي وبالتالي النتيجه هناك
ثابته حتى الان في المناطق اقصى الشرق
ابتداء من ارضها مرورا بمناطق الاكراد الى
ما بعدها عندما نتحدث ايضا الفرز ارتفع
الى 49
اقتربنا من تسعه واربعين وتسعه وثلاثين
نستطلع الان الامور فيما يتعلق بالارقام
الرئيس التركي 13 مليون و400000
كماله الجدار اولو كمال وصل الى اكثر من
عشره ملايين تقريبا يعني الفرق بينهم حتى
الان ثلاثه ملايين لصالح الرئيس التركي
رجب بعد فرز ما يقرب من 50 بالمئه 49.39
الارقام ستاتي لكن بالمقارنه مع المره
السابقه يبدو الرئيس التركي في وضع افضل
بعد فرز يعني 50% من الاصوات هل هذا
سيعطيه القدره على الاستمرار لا نعلم حتى
الان لان هناك في مناطق اخرى لا زال الفرز
فيها مستمرا والنظر دائما على نسبه
المشاركه لكنها كما لاحظنا اقل من نسبه
المشاركه في الجوله الاولى في انتظار اي
تحديثات جديده نذكر بان مالك الجدار اولو
مرشح المعارضه في هذه الانتخابات لا زال
عند
43.64 من مجموعه صناديق التي فرزت حتى
الان الرئيس التركي في المقدمه بسته
وخمسين فاصله 36 بعد فرز ما يقرب من 50
تسعه واربعين فاصله تسعه وثلاثين واذا بعد
قليل سنحاول ان نتعمق اكثر في تفاصيل ما
الذي يجري فيما يتعلق بالولايات التي
نصفها دائما بان الولايات متارجحه اسطنبول
انقره وهاتاي وايضا في بعض المناطق التي
كان التركي يحتاج الى اصوات سنان اوران في
الجوله الاولى ولم يحسمها مثل دينزلي في
منطقه ايجا وايضا باليكا في منطقه مرمره
هل سيتمكن الرئيس التركي من استعادتها
سنحاول ان نفهم الوضع بعد قليل اذا تحديث
جديد للخريطه نحاول ان نذكر ببعض الاشياء
في المنطقه الجنوبيه هاتاي لا زالت باللون
البرتقالي يعني حتى هذه اللحظه وذكرنا مع
صهيب قبل قليل بانها كانت النسبه بين
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وكمالك في
الجوله الاولى جدا ضئيله يعني تعد بالالاف
حتى الان ما زالت باللون البرتقالي يعني
الرئيس التركي متقدم في هاتاي هاتاي من
حيث القوه الانتخابيه ليست كبيره لكن لها
رمزيه فيما يتعلق بان احدى الولايات
الاكثر تضررا من الزلزال الذي حصل فيه
فبراير الماضي فلذلك ينظر اليها من هذه
الزاويه بانها اهميه الاهم في المناطق
الجنوبيه بالنسبه لعموم تركيا عاده هي
اضنه واضن من الولايات المتضرره بدرجه اقل
من بقيه الولايات الاحدى عشر من الزلزال
الا انها الاصوات فيها حتى الان
ذهبت لصالح
كمال كالجدار اول وفاه ستبقى اضنه مع
كماله وهنا سنتحدث عن جزئيه ربما كانت
مؤثره في بعد اعلان نتائج الجوله الاولى
اذ خرجت اصوات كثيره تنتقد سكان مناطق
الزلزال
وايضا
وحتى ادرى فيما يتعلق بالبرلمانيات لماذا
اعطيتم اصواتكم للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بعد عدم كما يقولون المعارضه حزب
الشعب الجمهوري لم يديروا الوضع فيما
يتعلق بعمليات الانقاذ في الزلزال في
البرلمانيات هذه المناطق باكملها مناطق
الزلزال تقريبا مع عدد ديار بكر
ذهبت للرئيس التركي رجل طيب اردوغان ما
الذي حصل حصل موقف اخر هنا في تكرداو
في ذكر دافي اقصى الشمال الغربي كان هناك
مجموعه من سكان مناطق الزلزال يعيشون في
فنادق ايواء
الميزانيه من البلديه في صبيحه نتائج
الانتخابات طرد هؤلاء السكان الذين يعودون
الى مناطق الزلازل من تلك الفنادق بحجه
بحسب مدير او بحسب رئيس بلديه تكردا بانهم
لا ليس لديهم ميزانيه لايوائهم فسنراقب
الان هل ستتغير النتائج فيما يتعلق بنسبه
التصويت لصالح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان بناء على هذا المعطى لانه كان
هناك رد فعل كبير من سكان هذه المناطق
بانه لماذا تلوموننا على استخدام حقنا
الانتخابي للتصويت للرئيس التركي رغم ما
جرى من اثار للزلزال فسنراقب هذه النقطه
الان ارتفاع نسبه التصويت هناك من عدمه ام
لا